mais ces gens d'années qui peut mener
une ferme à la faillite
ce genre de ces chaises ça arrive et
cela nuit vraiment à l'industrie au sein
de spir
pendant longtemps des vides baeck ch'ti
dépend des de la pluie pour ses cultures
mais depuis trois ans cet agriculteur du
sud de l'alberta a accès à l'irrigation
maintenant irrigué parce que les
autorités ont fait un très bon travail
de préservation
et c'est tout supplémentaire peut être
partagé avec plus d'agriculteurs
c'est une décision évidente cela réduit
sans aucun doute les risques augmentent
le rendement et améliore notre situation
économique
[Musique]
l'irrigation est très importante en
alberta la province possède à elle seule
les trois quarts de tous les systèmes
d'irrigation au canada et la majeure
partie de ce système se trouve dans le
sud de la province l'irrigation assure
une production agricoles performantes
dans une région semi aride
l'irrigation a permis de doubler tripler
voire quadrupler la quantité de
nourriture que cette terre produit
tout cela est très convaincant
pour que tout ce système d'irrigation
fonctionne il faut beaucoup d'eau
nous trouvons devant l'un des principaux
réservoirs d'irrigation
lors que vous voyez ici provient des
montagnes rocheuses à l'arrière
bach
comme nous pouvons le voir ce réservoir
est plein l'hiver 2020 2021 a été traîné
jeunes
le chercheur stéphane kinsley de
l'université devait bridge en alberta
analyse l'apport en eau dans les
prairies du sud de la province en lien
avec l'évolution du climat il a compilé
toutes les données climatiques des 70
dernières années pour tout le territoire
de l'alberta
combien de jours de gel il y a eu
combien de jours en dessous de moins 20
degrés combien de jours au-dessus de 30
degrés combien de jours de pluie quelle
est la durée d'une saison de croissance
au total de calcul 55 indice climatique
ces données lui permettent d'avoir un
portrait exact des tendances climatiques
son constat est alarmant le climat
change rapidement
ici les hivers sont beaucoup plus courts
qu'auparavant et nous avons deux saisons
de croissance beaucoup plus longue
dans cette région la saison de
croissance est d'environ trois semaines
plus longue aujourd'hui qu'elle ne
l'était dans les années 50
[Musique]
ce qui va de pair avec des températures
plus élevées est une augmentation des
taux d'évaporation
cela signifie que nous aurons durant
l'été plus de pertes vers l'atmosphère
provenant de sources d'eau tels que le
réservoir ici
mais le plus gros problème est que les
soldes vont se dessécher davantage parce
que nous avons une saison de croissance
plus longue
[Musique]
il est clair pour lui qu'une plus longue
saison de croissance n'est pas une bonne
nouvelle dans un contexte où l'eau se
fait de plus en plus rares
[Musique]
promesse le problème c'est qu'un
réservoir d'irrigation comme celui ci ne
contient contre un et deux ans de au
maximum et rhinois
si nous avions une sécheresse qui devait
durer plus de deux ans alors ces
réservoirs ne fournirait pas
l'histoire a déjà démontré à plusieurs
reprises que des sécheresses sur
plusieurs années peuvent frapper ici
la dernière en tête s'est déroulé durant
les années 1930 il y a également eu les
sécheresses de 2001 et de 2002 qui ont
fait très mal
en examinant les tendances climatiques
des soixante dix dernières années avec
des taux d'évaporation accrue et trop de
précipitation des croissants et des
soldes globalement plus asséché et en
même temps avec des réserves d'eau
insuffisante alors nous avons un énorme
défi de maintien d'un approvisionnement
en eau oui à ce challenge
[Musique]
l'agriculteur dévide bekhti a profité il
ya trois ans de l'agrandissement du
système d'irrigation en alberta il est
très conscient qu'il a accès à une
ressource limitée 6 pourquoi ils
utilisent toutes les technologies
disponibles qui permettent de réduire la
consommation d'eau
je crois en la conservation nous
utilisons une ressource disponible mais
sans en abuser nous l'utilisons
intelligemment
[Musique]
nous utilisons seulement la quantité
d'eau dont nous avons besoin pour sa
culture jacques arroseurs est muni d'une
buse spécifique qui distribue une
quantité différente à chaque minute
ce sont des sommités du solde et j'ai
installé
les utilisent pour gérer le système
d'irrigation
quelle est la quantité d'eau de pluie
les niveaux des bateaux transpiration la
quantité d'eau que la culture utilisent
nous nous assurons et les plans ne
manque pas d'eau ou ne reçoivent pas
trop 2011 à face à
tout ça
il y à des technologies que nous
n'utilisons pas encore mais qui je pense
seront un jour très utile l'irrigation
goutte à goutte par exemple fourni
l'exacte quantité d'eau dont la plante a
besoin ce système existe mais pas ici
parce que ce n'est pas encore
économiquement viable mais ce sera
peut-être un jour un gourbi samedi
[Musique]
les eaux qui dévalent les rocheuses en
alberta traverse toutes les prairies
elles servent aux grandes villes à
l'écosystème et aussi à toute une
agriculture mais l'alberta a
l'obligation de partager un minimum
d'eau avec la saskatchewan et le
manitoba un traité géré par le
gouvernement fédéral stipule que
l'alberta doit laisser 50% de
l'écoulement naturel des rivières à la
saskatchewan qui à son tour doit laisser
passer 50 % du débit vers le manitoba
c'est un accord très simple mais en
pratique c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
car 50% de pas grand chose ça donne très
peu surtout si vous vous situez en avant
le stress
[Musique]
la saskatchewan veut aussi agrandir son
système d'irrigation pour améliorer sa
propre production agricole
[Musique]
un projet de 4 milliards de dollars
propose de dériver plus d'eau du lac
diefenbaker une eau qui provient aussi
de l'alberta
il ne faut pas oublier que l'eau est une
ressource limitée si elle nous semble
plus abondant en ce moment c'est en
raison de la fonte des glaciers cette
plus grande quantité d'eau peut faire
croire qu'il y en aurait assez pour
étendre les zones d'irrigation mais nous
devons faire attention il faut examiner
la variabilité des futurs débit des
rivières et leur capacité à soutenir
tous les usages
il
la rivière milk dans l'extrême sud de
l'alberta est un bon exemple des défis
de gestion de l'eau cette rivière prend
sa source dans les rocheuses du montana
entre en alberta pour ensuite retourner
vers les états unis où elle se jette
dans la rivière missouri une entente
entre le canada et les états-unis gère
le partage de l'eau de la rivière milk
les canadiens ont droit à 25 % du débit
mais en juillet 2021 tous les
agriculteurs du nord de la frontière
doit fermer le robinet de l'irrigation
car n'y a pas assez d'eau dans la
rivière c'est la troisième fois en cinq
ans que cela arrive
cette fermeture nous ne l'anticipions
pas aussitôt que le 9 juillet
coupez-les aussi rapidement va diminuer
nous récolte de 25 à 40%
nous devons faire quelque chose il nous
devons le faire maintenant l'eau est
cruciale elle est notre futur
nous devons assurer notre
approvisionnement en ont si nous voulons
garder nos gens et nous ferme ici
[Musique]
il y a plus de sens tant la rivière milk
était la source du tout premier conflit
d'usagé d'eau entre le canada et les
états unis
ce conflit a mené à la création de la
commission mixte internationale qui gère
toutes les eaux frontalières telle la
rivière milk mais aussi les grands cours
d'eau comme le fleuve columbia les
grands lacs où le fleuve saint laurent
larivière milk est un indicateur de ce
que nous pourrions éventuellement voir
ailleurs lorsque la stabilité hydrique
est compromise par le manque de neige et
de glace
nous savons maintenant à quoi ressemble
de vraie pénurie d'eau c'est loin d'être
laid